welcome to scitrick your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
we live in a reboot society everything
has to be remade repackaged redone
but that got me thinking if there was a
tv show from back in the day that i
wanted to see being remade and rebooted
which would it be
and my first answer the first thing that
came to my mind
book rogers of the 25th century now it
turns out
there is a plan to have this show
rebooted
george clooney's production company
smokehouse is already apparently in the
preliminary stages of planning legendary
entertainment who were commissioned in
this series
want to create a whole franchise they
want to create movies tv shows and
perhaps even an anime style animated
series
they want to create this as a
multi-platform
franchise for their future
there is also a second company skydance
productions
they are also trying to create their own
project
both of these production companies seem
to think that they own the rights so
obviously
we might be seeing a bit of a complex
legal battle but we'll come to that a
bit later so i only really come to this
from a book rogers in the 21st century
1979 tv series that is my
access to the show that is that is
really my knowledge of this character it
turns out he's a much older character
than that however this character is
actually about 100 years old
it all dates back to a novella called
armageddon 24 19.
that short book written by philip
francis nolan
the character is actually named anthony
anthony rogers
he was a mining engineer trapped
underground there was some sort of
accident he was cryogenically frozen and
he woke up in the 25th century
in that series the planet was being
invaded by um some alien threat and
there was an interplanetary conflict
going on and a lot of the stories about
how anthony rogers then sort of adapted
to this new century in 1929 that was
then turned into a comic book strip
series
they changed the name to book rogers
thank god and the new character was born
other elements of this story were also
changed he became a world war one
veteran that was trapped underground and
cryogenically frozen there was some sort
of radiation gas involved and it all got
a bit complicated but back in the day in
the 20s they thought radiation could do
anything they thought it was awesome um
radioactive spider bites you don't die
turn into spiderman now the 1979 series
obviously didn't follow that original
comic book story line in that series
series again the earth is in a planetary
conflict with the draconians
in the comic book series though and the
series that apparently george clooney
and smokehouse productions want to take
this
the earth is actually being invaded and
occupied by an alien threat
buck rogers then joins the resistance
and fights back against this threat
now the 1979 tv series
knew to have a little bit of humour
glennae larson's tv shows generally had
a little bit of humor involved in them
battlestar galactica airwolf going on
and on and on they're also a little bit
camp
i actually think that for a tv series
like this to be successful it needs to
embrace the fact that the plot of the
story is a little bit ridiculous it gets
frozen and wakes up 500 years later that
plot is slightly silly and you need to
embrace that like they did in demolition
man it also gives you the opportunity to
inject a little bit of humor
in stargate sg-1 they knew to have a
little bit of humor they need to have a
little bit of tongue-in-cheek some
sarcasm some jokes referencing other tv
shows and things like this then you know
embracing the silliness
book rogers in the 25th century has to
do that too and i actually think george
clooney would know that
he's not a stranger to injecting a
little bit of humor into his projects
the men that stare at goats is one that
jumps to mind that's actually quite a
serious movie in lots of ways but it's
ridiculous in other ways they completely
embraced how stupid the plot was even
though it was actually based on true
story
but if you consider how much our
community and how how much our society
has just changed in the last 30 to 40
years
how is could it change over the next
four five hundred years
especially as in this storyline the
earth has had a massive nuclear conflict
world war iii
and obviously has then been invaded by
an alien threat
society might have changed massively
how does he then adapt to that is going
to be a really interesting plotline so
the legal battle
the basic problem comes from the fact
that this is a very old character
now the family the nolan family saying
they own the rights
their grandad wrote to the original
story therefore they own the character
of book rogers
however it's not quite that simple
one of the producers supposedly for the
new series is john f dill now john f
dill's grandad was one of the creators
of the comic strip
legendary pictures say they solely own
the rights to book rogers skydance say
they do and have issued a cease and
desist letter to legendary pictures
saying you are not to make this series
you must stop all action immediately
where it gets a little bit even more
complicated however if when you've got a
character that's 100 years old copyright
laws get a little bit
fuzzy
if you think about the sherlock holmes
character the arthur conan doyle
estate own elements to that story they
copyrighted elements to the original
stories
but they don't really own the character
sherlock holmes this is why netflix can
produce anola homes
we get other series that are based in
and around the character and they don't
have to pay the doyle family estate
massive
royalty fees
a lot of the character exists within the
public domain and that complicates
copyright law so that basically means we
could see both of these projects
actually come to fruition but let's be
honest neither of the production
companies are going to want the other
one to do it because it's going to
affect their profits so there is almost
certainly going to be a massive legal
battle and probably one of the main
reasons why this project hasn't really
moved on since back in january when it
was announced
but what is the main thing we have to
see if this series is rebooted
what is the number one thing you
remember from book rogers in the 25th
century
it's the thunder fighter
that fighter is one of the best designs
in sci-fi for me it's right up there
with like the x-wing or a tie fighter or
the viper from battlestar galactica
interesting pointing glen a larson
obviously produced both these shows
battlestar galactica and book rogers in
the 25th century they shared a lot of
the props to save money they used they
recycled a lot of the um props and the
the um sets and things
the design for the thunder fighter
though
was actually the original concept design
for the viper the viper was supposed to
look like this this design has to come
back it was one of my favorite designs
when i was a kid i had the toy
and if they don't bring it back that
will be a crime against all of scifi and
we will have to punch george clooney in
the face for it
so
what do i think is this show going to
come back
i think almost certainly yes
in what guys and what the legal battle
is between now and then i don't know but
i could see a stream of service like
netflix being desperate for this show
they
badly need content and they always
looking for that next big thing
and this so could be it
star trek its popularity is pretty good
at the moment but there's always that
threat of getting a bit bored of it we
had voyager and then we had enterprise
and people got a bit of star trek
fatigue and i think there's a risk of
that again
so we'll be looking for that next big
thing that next big sci-fi project
this could be that
and it really does give the opportunity
for a really nice balance between the
drama and certain comedy elements that
really i think make a beautiful sci-fi
show but also that reflects society and
i know people are going to say oh
they're going to make it work they'll
make book rogers a woman i don't care
really if they do or not if it's
relevant to the show
but there are elements within our
divided society the book rodgers in the
25th century could exploit and could
reflect within the show to make it a
really interesting project
so i hope they do bring back book rogers
in the 25th century
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification so you see all of our new
videos pop up it really really helps us
out
[Music]